the Trump campaign is in total and utter
chaos remember not long ago when Donald
Trump fired that outrageous campaign
manager Corey Lewandowski and replaced
him with Paul Manafort remember when all
sorts of connections between Paul
Manafort and pro-russian groups surfaced
including the New York Times allegation
that 12.7 million dollars in payments
potentially illegal payments were in a
handwritten ledger for mana Ford and his
organization all of that was of course
denied by the Trump campaign and yet
Paul Mann afford has now been
effectively fired as Trump's campaign
manager although in name he will remain
the campaign chairperson to I guess make
it seem like they're not in total and
utter chaos Paul Manafort is basically
out as the effective manager of the
campaign almost as quickly as he was in
he has been replaced sit down for this
he has been replaced by two people
number one this Republican strategist
and pollster Kellyanne Conway okay I
sort of understand that she knows more
about how Republicans can appeal to
women and she has some expertise there
make sense although she's been a pretty
aggressive bomb thrower on CNN for the
last six months and Breitbart news CEO
Steve Bannon this is the same Breitbart
news that parrots all sort of conspiracy
theories including all of the recent
unfounded allegations about Hillary
Clinton being very very ill and on the
verge of death seemingly he now is going
to be the co campaign manager for Donald
Trump along with Kellyanne Conway uh
this comes the day after we learned
about numerous reports that serial
sexual assault accuse II actually I'm
sorry I want to speak clearly this
evening serial sexual harassment accuse
e note the word that that the use of the
word accuse e and former fox news chief
roger ailes is also advising Donald
Trump and as I mentioned Paul Manafort
is going to stay on is the campaign
chairman clearly just for PR purposes to
make it seem like less of a shake-up
than it really is so think about it
Trump's campaign is now being advised
managed by a combination of Roger Ailes
a right-wing bomb thrower who is
currently facing over 20 accusations of
sexual harassment in his role at Fox
News and the guy who directs Breitbart
news a total right-wing bomb-throwing
website that also regularly publishes
unfounded conspiracies the real question
Lois is not to figure out exactly how
nuts these people are but to think about
what they can possibly do to the Trump
campaign well one is put Trump on a
teleprompter right we stop all press
conferences and casual question answer
periods put Trump on a teleprompter
limit his interviews craft the message
very very specifically course we know
Trump seems crazy when he reads from a
teleprompter might not be the best idea
the other possibility and I mention this
because Breitbart has been a key player
in the Hillary is really sick conspiracy
theories like physically health-wise
sick maybe they can just frame the
entire Trump campaign no it's never been
about issues other than crazy stuff like
ban Muslims they could just make the
entire campaign about hey Trump is
healthy and Hilary isn't and try to
pivot to that I'm thinking out loud here
I don't know what they're going to do
yeah well Trump's campaign is is kind of
a UH kind of a mess kind of a disaster
so do they say are there are these
people whose are thinking we need to
clean this up a bit this needs to be
cleaner sleeker less insane Donald Trump
needs to shut up and stop putting his
foot in his mouth uh or are they going
to go down the Breitbart route yeah and
oh boy if you thought it was ugly before
a lot of people are saying now it's
actually going to get ugly really yet
what was it before I mean that's amazing
I can't wait for the finger-pointing
right i mean so many people have been in
and out it's been like a revolving door
in this abortive campaign that at this
point i would believe that divine you
know we always say it's so pompous to
think that God if he or she exists gets
involved in the politics in one election
cycle in one country on one continent in
one on one planet in one solar system in
one galaxy of this amazing universe that
he or she created I would actually
believe it if somehow
is able to turn this around and put
together what seems like a normal
campaign I would only believe that it
were possible through divine
intervention well I'd go the opposite uh
with that I would say that if it's
possible for Donald Trump to become
president uh intelligent design is a
farce and were really just incredibly
dumb creatures that did come from uh
fish in single cell organisms